je comprends que je prends le matin de
bonne heure et je suis très heureux
d'être là parmi vous monsieur le
président de l'association des maires de
france et président d'intercommunalité
cher françois baroin
monsieur le premier vice président
délégué andré laignel monsieur le
secrétaire général cher philippe laurent
je voudrais saluer ceux qui sont autour
de moi
à cet instant à cette tribune même le
professeur est saluée
carole delga mais qui j'ai partagé deux
journées au mois de septembre dans sa
région
salut et pierre jarlier et puis ça lui
aussi mes collègues maires ici présents
et le président et vice président
délégué de la délégation collectivités
territoriales accompagné protos gatel
qui est là comme agnès le brun qui ne
quitte plus le sénat et qui vient
d'accepter de se délocaliser
après deux journées partagez et vous
tous je suis heureux d'ouvrir cette
séquence de votre congrès consacré à un
thème majeur pour tous les élus de la
république décentralisation déclin ou
audace il ya quelques années ce thème
aurait pu paraître curieux en effet
depuis 1982 puis l'acte 2 de la
décentralisation
porté par le président jacques chirac
depuis cet acte de l'article 1er de
notre constitution dispose que
l'organisation de notre république est
décentralisée
l' affaire paraissait donc entendu est
d'autant plus attendu qu'il ya encore
seulement quelques mois le président de
la république emmanuel macron avait
promis je le cite un pacte girondins
suscitant un réel espoir espoir
entretenu avec la mise en place c'était
le 17 juillet 2010 est d'une conférence
nationale des territoires qui avait pour
objectif je cite là aussi de renouer la
confiance entre l'état et les
collectivités espoir à ce jour déçu tant
la pratique gouvernementale s'est écarté
des discours tant le dialogue promis
s'est transformé en leçon réunion après
réunion
au point de conduire régions de france
l'assemblée des départements de france
et l'association des maires de france à
prendre une décision décision de se
retirer de la conférence nationale des
territoires au mois de juillet dernier
pointant une recentralisation sans
précédent alors de quoi parle-t-on
lorsque on évoque la décentralisation
de quoi parle-t-on lorsqu'on évoque un
pacte girondins c'est retombe n'avait pu
penser qu en usant de cette expression
le président de la république avait
souhaité rendre un hommage particulier à
ses deux enfants de la révolution si
chère au coeur de françois barrault 1
que sont la commune et le département
ap après un peu plus d'une année
je crains que l'exécutif ne se soit en
réalité davantage référer à la vision de
la décentralisation cave et le doyen
maurice hauriou à la fin du 19e siècle
écoles de toulouse madame belga et oui
une décentralisation conçu et je cite le
doyen comme une manière d'être de l'état
faisant ainsi peu de cas des libertés
locales auquel nous sommes tant attachés
mais depuis cette époque il semble que
l'état ait oublié les bonnes manières
dans ses relations avec les
collectivités
il serait même parfois adepte des
mauvaises manières une décentralisation
réussie
suppose d'abord un réel respect des élus
l'épisode de la communication sur la
taxe d'habitation en est le
contre-exemple absolue et je ne veux
même plus et forums formuler ce qui a
été une expression très populiste cette
année cette année le président de la
république a préféré la forme
épistolaire pour rendre compte des
engagements qu'il avait pris devant vous
cette décision lui appartient je la
respecte mais pour ma part je préfère
malgré tout la rencontre directe à la
formule plus distanciée de l'écrit dans
sa lettre le président de la république
rend hommage au maire qu'il décrit comme
des passionnés de l'intérêt général
il a raison et c'est d'abord l'intérêt
général de notre pays sa situation que
je souhaite évoquer ce matin n'oublions
pas qu'en mai 2010 est l'élection
présidentielle a fait apparaître au
premier tour l'existence de quatre blocs
que 40% des suffrages exprimés se sont
portés sur les extrêmes de notre
échiquier politique
je ne suis pas certain que la situation
politique et beaucoup évolué depuis
cette période s'était pourtant les
changes que j'avais eue avec le
président de la république quand il
avait eu l' extrême courtoisie à la
veille de la cérémonie d'investiture de
me rendre visite au sénat et il m'avait
dit président comment vous sentez les
choses je lui avais dit n'oubliez jamais
le premier tour car le premier tour nous
fait un devoir de cohésion nous fait un
devoir de républicains je donnais pas la
leçon mais je voulais simplement dire
que pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel
alors la fragmentation n'est pas que
politique non plus elle est aussi
territoriales les fractures
territoriales se sont encore aggravés
entre villes moyennes petites villes
territoires ruraux certains territoires
périurbains et des métropoles de
dimension européenne
nulle intention dans mon esprit de les
opposer nous avons besoin des métropoles
mais comme si peu reprendre la partage
et j'en avais fait un rapport au
président de la république françois
hollande en 2015 la formule récente du
géographe qui lie au fort paris est plus
proche de londres d'amsterdam ou de
barcelone que d'aurillac ou de moulins
voilà la réalité qui risquent de
fragmenter notre pays
cette peinture territoriales ce double
parfois d'une fracture sociologique
j'ai lu avec beaucoup d'intérêt jean
viard dans la croix cette semaine pour
lui il est nécessaire de revoir les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de la
transition écologique
il ne doit plus être conçue que par un
prisme strictement urbain mais bien être
pensés pour être acceptable par
l'ensemble du pays
le discours sur l'écologie ne doit pas
être réduit aux déplacements à vélo ou
en véhicule électrique qu'en plus de 70%
de concitoyens utilisent leur véhicule
pour travailler pour un trajet moyen je
le rappelle 25 km à l'est 25 km autour
et que 40% d'entre eux n'ont qu'un choix
alternatif la transition écologique doit
prendre en compte la situation de nos
compatriotes de la classe moyenne qui
vivent dans ce milieu dans ce milieu
rural de petites villes et périurbain
sans transport collectif perco et ce
besoin de compréhension au fond
s'exprime ces jours ci de manière forte
au travers d'un mouvement que je n'ai
pas besoin de qualifier que vous avez
tous sens faites et qui porte une
couleur jaune mais qui est la france
d'un côté que je décrivais en 2015
simplement vous souvenir que notre
rapporteur spécial au sénat c'est au
journal officiel de la république jean
françois husson sénateurs de meurthe et
moselle
disait le 24 novembre 2010 est lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
notamment sur la question de la taxation
des carburants qui ne voulaient pas voir
naître et je cite une nouvelle vague de
bonnet rouge
est ce la prescience la seule chose sur
lequel ils soient trompés c'est la
couleur
le président de la république appelle
l'ensemble des forces vives du pays à
regarder dans la même direction
il faut que cette direction sera la
bonne encore faut-il que les instruments
de mesure soit adaptée et la vision
partagée
c'est comme le pouvoir d'achat y la dgf
les chiffrages macroéconomiques c'est
une facette de la réalité mais ce n'est
pas la réalité vécue concrètement par
nos concitoyens et les élus des
territoires
cela alimente le sentiment d'abandon
d'un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
le risque nous le connaissons c'est le
passé du sentiment d'abandon n'oublie
parfois de mépris à une réaction de
sécession face à ce risque de sécession
vous les maires et jusqu'il ya peu j'ai
partagé ce destin de mère ou rester des
remparts de la république
c'est d'ailleurs vers vous que nos
concitoyens se tourner quand tout va mal
la commune c'est la cellule de base de
notre démocratie locale
on le répète sans cesse mais c'est une
vraie réalité c'est l'entité locale
d'administration par excellence celle
des bons et des mauvais jours celle à
laquelle s'identifie de concitoyens
c'est vrai nos concitoyens se montre
direct parfois même injuste avec leurs
élus locaux et en particulier leur mère
mais vous êtes quand même les seuls
auxquels ils font majoritairement
confiance car ils savent que les maires
et les élus municipaux n'ont qu'un but
dont vous avez fait la devise de ce
congrès est monsieur le président servir
le citoyen et agir pour la république
monsieur le président oui c'est vrai
qu'ils sont exigeants mais là aussi je
préfère le hashtag ma commune j'y tiens
autres notre hashtag dans lequel on
avait expliqué que les élus étaient bons
à jeter aux orties servir le citoyen et
agir pour la république c'est pour le
maire une belle mission une mission qui
peut changer directement la vie des gens
et je voudrais vous citez lisant j'ai
quelques jours dans le journal l'union
les propos d'une de nos collègues de la
marne elle dit très justement c'est
madame le maire de sept saulx on a mis
en place une garderie la cantine on
améliore la vie des gens et des services
qui n'existait pas auparavant
c'est ça la réalité d'une commune de 650
habitants
ce n'est pas une structure froide
abstraite technocratique
c'est au fond la collectivité de la vie
des gens et la commune ce n'est pas
qu'une structure c'est d'abord une
communauté humaine
c'est une communauté citoyenne autour
desquels quand tout va mal
les citoyens se retrouvent je les ai
vécus il y à peu à trèbes
autour du maire deux fois deux fois
crucifiés
au cours de cette année madame délicat
bien en tête cette rencontre sans
imaginer ce qui allait se passer
un mois après mais pour apporter de
nouveaux services encore faut-il en
avoir les moyens
disposez d'une réelle autonomie d'action
encore faut-il en amour que la
décentralisation est un plein sens
l'étude réalisée par le cevipof le
montre en voit poindre le découragement
et je le mesure très bien leur met des
déplacements dans les départements le
sentiment de dépossession de certains
maires des élus municipaux
que ce soit en raison des contraintes
financières qui souhaitent aller
croissant ou du fait
de l'art en composition intercommunale
je ne m'appesantirai pas sur la mise en
oeuvre de la contractualisation
financière chacun connaît sa manière
verticale président de la république
dans sa lettre indique que 99% des
communes ne sont pas concernés c'est
d'oublier cela n'a pas échappé au
président du comité des finances locales
que la loi de programmation des finances
publiques entend limiter la croissance
des dépenses pour l'ensemble des
communes mais sans recourir pour le
moment je reprends un texte un
dispositif coercitif
dans cette même lettre le président de
la république reconnaît que la mise en
oeuvre accélérée de la réforme de
l'intercommunalité sur certains
territoires et l'application mécanique
est parfois trop stricte de la loi sur
la nouvelle organisation territoriale de
la république ont pu être source de
dysfonctionnements et de déception
citation de la lettre en disant cela
crois que le président fait à pas qui
était nécessaire il faut maintenant
passer aux actes pour remédier aux
dysfonctionnements apaiser les
descriptions et redonner des
perspectives le nombre élevé de
démission de maire mais aussi de
conseillers municipaux qui ont le
sentiment de ne plus beaucoup compté
nous interpelle
c'est dans cette perspective que le
sénat placé ses travaux c'est dans cette
perspective qu'il agira de mai mois qui
viennent car maintenant après nous être
rencontrer écrit voici venu le temps de
l'action au sénat notre vision des pas
celle d'une décentralisation sur le
déclin
je réponds monsieur le président à votre
première question
nous croyons fermement que la
décentralisation est une chance pour
notre pays
alors notre vision à nous est à
l'audacieuse point d'interrogation et
son audacieux de considérer que la
légitimité du suffrage universel
vaut mieux que les décisions
technocratiques interrogation est-ce
audacieux ne défendent les principes de
libre administration et d'autonomie
financière et fiscale des collectivités
territoriales interrogations s
dassieu de penser que toutes les règles
ne doivent pas été dictée de paris est
appliquée de manière uniforme sur le
territoire interrogations et son
audacieux de vouloir veiller à
l'équilibré des territoires petite ville
comme métropole territoires ruraux comme
quartiers de la politique de la ville
interrogation est-ce audacieux enfin de
miser sur les élus locaux de la
république pour développer et maintenir
la cohésion de notre pays
alors dans ce cas oui notre vision est
audacieuse cette vision audacieuse nous
la partageons avec vous association des
maires de france association des
départements de france et régions de
france rassemblés au sein de territoires
unis c'est le sens de l'appel de
marseille
c'est le sens de l'accord de rennes qui
vous ont été présentés doit maintenant
s'ouvrir vraiment une nouvelle étape de
la décentralisation je dis bien une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
nouvelle étape fondée sur les libertés
locales sur le respect et la
reconnaissance des élus sur la proximité
la subsidiarité sur la différenciation
territoriale et l'expérimentation dans
le respect de l'unité de la république
c'est d'abord une décentralisation qui
repose sur le respect et la
reconnaissance des élus
le respect c'est de considérer les élus
comme de vrais partenaires les élus
je le redis département après
département ne sont pas les chefs de
bureaux de la préfecture
ils ne sont pas non plus des majeures
sous tutelle les citoyens français ne
sont pas des enfants
l'administration n'est pas là pour
brider les élus qui ont été désigné par
le suffrage universel
c'est fondamental si l'on veut pouvoir
restaurer un dialogue ça il sera entre
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales et j'appelle à ce dialogue
et de manière assez sentent je pense que
ce dialogue est essentiel pour la
cohésion de la république
la reconnaissance 2e pilier
c'est accepter de relever les conditions
d'exercice des mandats locaux
notre délégation collectivités
territoriales que préside jean marie
bockel vient de rendre public
c'était il ya un peu plus d'un mois 43
proposition élaborée par de nombreux
collègues et louise des améliorations
très concrètes qui concerne le régime
indemnitaire avec une attention
particulière pour les maires des
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
elle concerne le régime social la
formation la reconversion ainsi que la
responsabilité pénale et la déontologie
à questionnaire vous va vous être
adressées sur la plateforme du sénat je
vous invite à vous y inscrire et
d'ailleurs nous allons poursuivre ce
dialogue en permanence avec vous les
élus de ce pays les perspectives
d'évolution des fonctions la complexité
croissante des conditions dans
lesquelles les élus locaux sont appelés
à agir appelle des réponses nouvelles de
président de la république m'a indiqué
qu'il souhaitait voir le gouvernement
s'inspirer de nos propositions alors
maintenant il va falloir passer aux
actes nous voulons une décentralisation
qui avec respect et reconnaissance mise
sur la proximité la subsidiarité une
décentralisation qui redonne du sens son
mandat municipal
clé de voûte de notre démocratie locale
moi je vous le dis je suis un militant
de l'intercommunalité
en 1999 j'ai terre dans l'opposition
j'ai voté la loi chevènement mais je
suis aussi lucide je constate qu'après
les réformes de 2010 et 2015
le peloton des élus locaux c'est tire
dangereusement avec des élus municipaux
pris dans de vastes ensembles
intercommunaux et qui parfois décroche
mathieu darnaud et le rapporteur de
notre mission de contrôle et de suivi
des loi de réforme territoriale avec
plusieurs de nos collègues de toute
sensibilité
il a analysé les enjeux de subsidiarité
de participation des mères aux instances
de décision des intercommunalités de
capacités des communes notamment rurales
d'exercer pleinement les compétences de
proximité et de service à la population
le principe de base
qui doit nous guider c'est celui de la
subsidiarité qui conjugue au mieux
l'efficacité et la proximité
on ne gagne rien à éloigner le citoyen
des centres de décisions faut mieux
associer les maires les élus municipaux
à la gouvernance des intercommunalités y
compris les conseillers municipaux qui
ne sont pas conseiller communautaire car
je sais que vous mener ce travail
mais le baromètre est terrible quand on
regarde le nombre de démissions des
conseils liés municipaux notamment qui
ne sont pas conseiller communautaire
notre délégation aux collectivités a
également engagé un travail visant à
recenser les bonnes pratiques qui
concerne l'association des élus
municipaux non conseillers
communautaires aux décisions des
intercommunalités
tout n'est pas du domaine législatif ou
réglementaire
c'est aussi notre rôle de mettre en
lumière les bonnes pratiques
maintenant il nous faut ajuster et ça
c'est une proposition concrète de
manière pragmatique les textes
législatifs et réglementaires en
particulier de la loi sur la nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république dans la lettre du président
de la république
il affirme qu'il y ait près qu'il a
demandé au préfet de faire des
propositions en ce sens mais je souhaite
tout simplement qu'il prenne la
proposition de loi du sénat votée en
juin où tout est présent c'est aussi ça
notre vision
[Applaudissements]
je compte sur l'assemblée nationale et
je le dis au président de la délégation
collectivités territoriales de
l'assemblée nationale pour se saisir de
ce texte
il est disponible on peut en quelques
mois monsieur le président et je vous
salue régler ces choses avec
l'enrichissement que vous apporterai et
je crois que alors qu'il y a réellement
urgence qui a réellement crise de
confiance que nous avons une
responsabilité des deux assemblées de
retrouver les chemins de la confiance et
d'un travail en commun qu'on évite
peut-être
les procédures eau et assainissement
dont on a connu un certain nombre de
suite qu'on aurait pu éviter
en évitant de se draper de part et
d'autre dans des postures parce que
pardonnez moi lol coule toujours du haut
vers le bas
il faut toujours l'assainir alors le
gouvernement doit faciliter la création
et la vie des communes nouvelles qui
peuvent être réponse positif
philippe siano pas que je vois il ya
beaucoup travaillé avec françoise gatel
dans une proposition de loi que nous
examinerons le 11 décembre et le
gouvernement devra surmonter ses propres
réticences là aussi faisons aux oeuvres
de pragmatisme
nous espérons vraiment cette ouverture
pour mettre en place des communes
communautés au moment où le président de
la république le gouvernement prône la
différenciation territoriales eh bien il
faut commencer par un peu de souplesse
de la dgcl
ça nous fera pas de mal nous voulons une
décentralisation qui favorise l'exercice
des libertés locales et l'adaptation
contraintes des territoires tout en
respectant je le dis l'unité de la
république auquel je suis tellement
attaché
parce que nous croyons dans les vertus
de la décentralisation dans le rôle des
élus locaux nous défendrons toujours
proximité et subsidiarité sommes
favorables à l'idée différenciation
territoriales pour mieux prendre en
compte les réalités locales les
aspirations des élus des innovations le
sida et même à sa source
pour les outre-mer il en a été
longuement question lundi c'est à
françois baroin lors de la journée des
élus d'outre-mer
le président de notre délégation a
souvent porté cette idée
c'est une nécessité pour l'outre-mer
mais on peut en parler aussi dans
l'hexagone en métropole ça n'est pas un
sujet interdit
nous voulons enfin une décentralisation
qui garantissent une pleine autonomie
financière et fiscale aux rapporteurs
spéciaux sont en train d'examiner
les budgets ce matin président la
république a décidé de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation il met en oeuvre son projet
présidentiel que les français ont choisi
je suis un démocrate et je respecte
cette décision mais comme c'est le cas
trop souvent il n'y a pas eu préalable
de réelle évaluation des conséquences de
cette décision
c'est en fait le même coin de table que
pour la taxe professionnelle j'ai par
contre en mémoire les paroles du
président de la république ici même et
rien ne vaut de revenir au verset 32 à
34 de son discours de l'an dernier je
veux garantir pleinement votre autonomie
financière et fiscale et donc je veux
qu'à l'issue de la réforme que nous
aurons à conduire les collectivités
territoriales et en particulier les
mairies et retrouver leur autonomie
fiscale pleine et entière
fin de citation ces paroles fortes
prononcé ici c'est un engagement pour
moi alors mettons le en neuf traduisant
ses principes en mesure effectif lors de
la refonte de la fiscalité locale que le
gouvernement annonce pour le premier
semestre
on doit le faire ensemble on doit le
faire ensemble
bien sûr l'exécutif bien sûr les deux
commissions des finances de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
et bien sûr avec les associations d'élus
ont convergera pas sur tout mais
j'allais dire changeons de méthode
on se fixe la calendrier et je crois que
nous pouvons avancer d'autant que j'ai
bien le sentiment j'ai bien le sentiment
que on ne pourra pas jouer les uns
contre les autres qu'il faudra qu'on
joue ensemble
ça nous fera du bien à tous couper le
lien fiscal
je le dis car nous ne sommes pas un état
fédéral
le rôle des élus territoriaux ça n'est
pas de gérer des financements octroyés
ou concédée c'est si nous faisions ainsi
passé du résident citoyens vers le
résident
consommateurs des services publics comme
le montre l'étude du cevipof
oui je pense que ce scénario final nous
devons l'écrire ensemble ce scénario cet
engagement me rappelleront également
lors de l'examen de la révision
constitutionnelle
mes chers collègues les groupes
politiques du sénat ont pris c'était en
janvier 2018
taïz exactement le 24 janvier 2018
une position unanime et je cite de
renforcer à l'article 72-2 de la
constitution des garanties d'autonomie
financière et fiscale des collectivités
territoriales le président de notre
commission des lois philippe bas le
rapporteur général de notre commission
des finances le président de la
commission des finances
vincent eblé ils sont particulièrement
vigilants voilà mes chers collègues
quelques unes des préoccupations qui
sont les nôtres alors décentralisation
je crois qu'il faut simplement faire
preuve d'audace écrire une nouvelle
étape et je crois que ça n'a rien
d'antinomique je crois que le temps de
la verticalité doit il fini pour le
temps de l'horizontalité dans les
relations que nous avons collectivités
territoriales et responsable exécutif
comme législatif plus que jamais avec
l'application de la loi sur la fin du
cumul des mandats
nous devons être proche de vous attentif
à bout dans le relais avec vous voilà
pourquoi avec mes collègues nous
arpentons le territoire nous l'emportons
pour être tout simplement en capacité de
porter ce que vous ressentez et à partir
de ce que vous ressentez d'établir un
diagnostic et de proposer me semble-t-il
en dépassant les clivages politiques une
réponse car comme le président de la
république
je crois vraiment que nous devons
réformer notre pays que nous devons le
redresser que j'entendais ce matin une
chronique économique stagner à 9% de
chômage dont on ne sortirait pas c'est à
terme porter atteinte à la cohésion
sociale territoriale humaine et mettre
en péril les valeurs de la république
car chaque commune est une petite
république dans la grande et en ces
temps où la république et quand même
interroger ou un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens ont perdu confiance dans
celles et ceux qui pourtant porte les
valeurs d'alternance je crois que plus
que jamais c'est dans ce dialogue là que
nous pourrons on ne réformera pas ce
pays sans contre les collectivités
territoriales on ne réformera pas ce
pays sans ou contre les élus alors vive
la commune vive la république et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]